- [Instructor] Have you ever thought about
how incredible the human body is?
For example, just to name a few things
that your body's already been doing today.
You are using your lungs
to take breaths in and out,
your heart's beating without stopping.
And your brain is coordinating
your body's functions,
and at the same time, helping
you understand this video.
All these body parts are made up of cells,
which as you might remember,
are the smallest units of life.
And it's so amazing
that trillions of cells,
without thoughts or
intentions of their own,
can come together to form something
as complex as the human body.
To help us understand how this occurs,
we have to understand how
the body is organized.
The human body has a
hierarchical organization,
meaning it's made up of nested layers,
each one more complex than the last.
In this case, four different
layers make up this hierarchy.
Cells, which make up tissues.
Tissues, which make up organs.
Organs, which make up organ systems.
And finally organ systems,
which help the human body
function as a whole.
So let's start with cells and tissues.
Cells are the smallest unit of life,
and the most basic level of organization
in the human body.
In the human body, not all
cells look or work the same.
Instead, they're specialized
to carry out different functions.
After cells, the next level
of organization is tissues.
A tissue is a collection of
similar, specialized cells.
And all of the cells that make
up a tissue are like a team.
They work together to ensure
the tissue works properly.
For instance, this image shows a section
of the type of epithelial tissue
that lines the inside of your mouth.
This particular tissue is
made up of epithelial cells,
which are specialized to
help protect your mouth
from wear and tear.
So the next time you're
eating a pointy tortilla chip,
remember how important
this epithelial tissue is.
Next up are organs and organ systems.
So organs are structures
that are made up of multiple
different types of tissues,
which all work together
to help the organ function.
And an organ system is a group
of organs that work together
to carry out complex
functions for the body.
For instance, the lungs
shown here in the diagram
are made up of several tissue types
that help them expand and contract.
These tissue types
include epithelial tissue,
which is the same type of
tissue we talked about earlier
in the mouth, and connective tissue.
And these tissues work
together so that the lungs
can carry out their role
in the respiratory system,
which is the organ system that allows us
to respire or breathe.
The respiratory system is
made up of multiple organs,
including the lungs, the trachea,
the nose and the diaphragm.
When we breathe, our diaphragm
which is this muscle
right here, contracts.
Air is pulled through
our nose and trachea,
and into our lungs.
Here, gas exchange happens
and our bodies take in oxygen
and get rid of carbon dioxide.
Then our diaphragm relaxes and we exhale.
The respiratory system,
and other organ systems
in the body, carry out specific functions
that work together to keep us alive.
And they do this mostly
without us even realizing it.
So it might get a little
tricky to remember
how all four levels of
organization cells, tissues,
organs and organ systems
relate to each other.
I like to think of these
four different levels,
almost like the Russian nesting dolls
that fit one inside another.
With cells being the
smallest doll on the inside.
So cells make up tissues.
Tissues make up organs.
And organs make up organ systems.
All of these components come together
to make up the human body.
So I hope you've learned
more about how our body's
organization helps us
thrive and stay alive.
So now use your brain to
tell your muscular system
to move your arm and give
yourself a pat on the back.
Because your body and its organized
hierarchical system is really awesome.